uh okay a Republican headquarters in
North Carolina was firebombed over the
weekend Republican Governor Pat McCrory
has called it an attack on democracy and
an act of political terrorism Hillsboro
police said that someone threw like a
flammable liquid through the window of
the Orange County's Republican
headquarters it set everything ablaze
the pictures are disturbing there was a
swastika found which said Nazi
Republicans get out of town or else
below it or above it spray paint cetera
now this really shouldn't be responded
to politically this is a crime uh it's
meant to intimidate it has no place in
politics the perpetrators must be found
prosecuted and held fully responsible
period but interestingly consider the
reactions from our two presidential
candidates here is a tweet Hillary
Clinton sent about this incident the
attack on the Orange County headquarters
office is horrific and unacceptable very
grateful that everyone is safe what
about Donald Trump here is a tweet from
Donald Trump about this incident animals
representing Hillary Clinton and
Democrats in North Carolina just
firebombed our office in Orange County
because we are winning now not that it
matters but Trump isn't winning in North
Carolina he's losing within the margin
of error but the real issue is how does
he know whether the actors represent
Hillary Clinton and Democrats how does
he know they don't represent
right-wingers who were upset with Trump
being the nominee how does he know it
wasn't the doing of a provocateur I
received two emails from people saying
David given what Donald Trump has done
and said this campaign I wouldn't put it
past Trump to coordinate a firebombing
of a Republican headquarters just so he
can blame it on Hillary Clinton in a
state where it's close and take
attention away from his own disastrous
campaign that goes pretty far but
there's a less conspiratorial argument
which is that the hate and culture of
violence that Trump is legitimized could
be just as much or or even more
responsible for what took place than
anything Hillary Clinton has done and oh
by the way a crowdfunding campaign led
by a Democrat has already raised
thirteen thousand bucks
rebuild the office there's a boston
democrat named David Weinberger of
brookline massachusetts who started a
campaign on GoFundMe to raise funds to
rebuild the facility 40 minutes after
the first donation came in they had
raised over 13,000 dollars from over 500
contributors surpassing the goal of
10,000 bucks and this was a Democrat who
decided to do this now that the one
confusion i have is reports say the
office is a total loss so i don't know
what you need the money for but i guess
it's to uh replace or go towards a new
office in some way anyway i know we sort
of have to be careful about
conversations like this because i don't
want to incite and it's anything but
this is a real conversation we have to
have i'm worried about election day
being pretty nasty and violent i
remember back in two thousand four when
george w bush was up for reelection it
was getting pretty bad back then and i
was sort of worried about violence and
people taking to the streets depending
on what the results were my concerns
this year are way way bigger when i look
at the vitriol and the violence that
we've already seen and the firebombing
mate may or may not be a sort of
directly related to the violence we
might see I'm pretty worried Pat about
the violence we might see particularly
if Trump loses on november nine yes
especially cuz what a third of the
electorate is gonna think that the
election was rigged and that our whole
democracy is a legitimate